honestly i think that nobody in colombia
know more about narco trafficker than me
[Music]
now the new generation think oh no no no
gorilla was fighting because they have
an ideology
now it's easy to to say that
these people doesn't understand
me like my generation understand what
happened
[Applause]
[Music]
the people who live that world
understand you
defend yourself or you you disappear
the armed revolutionary forces of
colombia known as the farc
is the most powerful guerrilla group in
the country they control the areas where
large amounts of the world's cocaine is
[Music]
produced
they are known as paramilitaries they
celebrate a legend of heroic defiance
against the kidnappers
the mission is to achieve what the army
cannot defeat the guerrillas
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
los pepes was a bunch of people who've
been affected by pablo escobar in
any way people who became
his enemy police people who paolo want
to kill
government people kidnapping or killed
by his people
all came together make a group
i am medico i've been part of the
narco-traffic world
i've been part of the pepe's group and
really close to auc
organization
[Music]
my family was working at the carol
business
in antioquia
i studied medicine and medina after that
i went to the medical school
i finished my degree
and at that time everything changed
my father was a normal businessman
imagine the only problem was that he was
rich
and that's why he was a really good
target
for escort
and my father was killed by his people
[Music]
that's why my life changed at that
moment because
immediately i take it step-by-step and
start to
fight and cooperate with them
i've been a doctor nobody was looking
for me
and i used that position to catch
information
against paolo scored people
and after that we was more proactive
12 died and more than 200 passers-by
were injured
in this recent explosion another outrage
was to follow
this time there was no mistaking the
culprit's identity
they'd left their signature at the scene
[Music]
pablo escobar couldn't stay out of the
public eye and that's what killed him
he died in a hail of bullets as he tried
to get away across a roof
at that time we feel like a heroes after
one that that war
[Music]
and we feel like all the territories
for us after a huge victory
[Music]
you